it's over anakin i have the high ground
you underestimate my power
don't try it if you've been having force
withdrawal symptoms since the
mandalorian season two wrapped
disney has what you need in the form of
some big star wars updates that dropped
this week
first of all major casting news for the
ewen mcgregor led obi-wan kenobi series
we've known for a while now that hayden
christensen would be returning to the
show set 10 years
after episode 3 but it gives this nerd
the good old goose pimples
actually seeing his face alongside
ewan's in the press release
curious to see just how much of anakin
is left 10 years into his career
as darth vader also returning our joel
edgerton and bonnie peace as uncle owen
and aunt beru
which stands to reason you might also be
seeing luke
as a little kid kicking up dirt on the
farm as well
as for the newcomers to star wars
including moses ingram camille nanjani
and many other talented actors
it'll be interesting to see what
characters if any from say rebels or the
various novels and comics based around
this time period
they pull into live action my personal
favorite part of this casting
announcement was the addition
of sun kang if star wars big enough for
two hans i mean he's not
gonna literally be a han probably but
listen i just have to put a justifying
reference in there somewhere
dominic tyrell you don't know me
you're about to going back to luke for a
minute i'm gonna go ahead and assume
that barring some wild new use of
disney's d
aging effects ten-year-old luke
skywalker is not the version fans want
sebastian stan to play
that said his the falcon and the winter
soldier co-star george st
pierre is joining the chorus of people
wanting the winter soldier
to take up a lightsaber as he told me in
a recent interview sebastian stanley
you know like everybody else i've heard
the rumor and i'm a huge star wars
fans and what i can say i i just hope we
get chosen to
portray to to get the the the iconic
character of luke skywalker i hope the
rumor is true because
as a big fan of star wars he said he's
an amazing actor and i
and i know he can take that on his
shoulder and deliver for the fans you
know so i hope the rumor is true
now with obi-wan kenobi and andor both
set for 2022 releases and the book of
boba fett coming this december
what can we watch sooner to give us our
fix
oh yeah what do you say kid you want to
come with us
how can i help
the clone wars have ended
you can either adapt and survive
or die with the past
the decision is yours
we do what we do while the quality of
the star wars films have been
hotly debated the star wars animated
shows have been consistently good if not
great
so there's no reason to believe the bad
batch will be any different the trailer
released this week gives us a proper
look at the tone of the series
while showing the return of some major
characters
including tarkin fennec saw guerrera and
rex yeah what a time to be alive
the bad batch is premiering on may the
4th with an extra long episode
i'm sure it's already marked on your
calendar but why not get a nice reminder
from me which new star wars series are
you most excited for what characters
would you love to see make their
live-action debuts in obi-wan kenobi
let's talk about it in the comments
below and i'll see you next time
you